It's going to be an exciting afternoon
here and an exciting we are billing this
part of the program is the Friday night
debates and we're beginning not at night
but at 1:30 in the afternoon on the
topic of Islam threat or not. to
moderate the panel. It gives me a great
pleasure to introduce the war
correspondent for WorldNet Daily, one of
the most watched uh internet sites in
the world. Uh frequent traveler to
Afghanistan, the Middle East uh and
Europe, where among other things uh he
is a panelist on the French version of
Meet the Press. So if you're a fan of
kiosk in Paris, you already know Matthew
Sanchez, please join me in welcoming him
now. and the very difficult task of
getting this program going. Okay,
[sighs] good afternoon. It's a pleasure
to be here. Um, just a couple of
personal comments. Before I became a war
correspondent, uh, I had the pleasure of
going to Kuwait and going into Iraq with
our troops, American forces, and I met a
lot of different people. My idea about
Islam was very limited, but I recall
being a Rammani and celebrating Ramadan
and being with a lot of different people
who were Muslims and uh and just feeling
how much it resembled Christmas. Uh
people got together, families ate and it
was a big celebration. There was nothing
violent about it.
That was always juxtaposed with
acts of violence that took place from
Islamists who during that Rammani
celebration 1997 of last year exploded
uh a car bomb and ended up killing up
killing the host of the party where I
was that day and that was a gentleman
named Shake Satar. So, is Islam a threat
or is it a peaceful religion? Honestly,
I couldn't tell you. And I think a lot
of you are here asking some of the same
questions. How much of a threat and how
much of an involvement we in the United
States will have with this force that
seems to be growing.
Here to discuss this are two gentlemen
who are much more intelligent than I
ever will be on the subject. Um, I'm
going to bring up Dr. Daniel Peterson.
He's a professor of Islamic studies at
Brigham Y Young University. He has
completed a biography on the life of
Muhammad.
To debate the doctor will be Robert
Spencer. Robert Spencer uh you may know
him by some of the the books that he he
has two New York Times bestsellers. one
is uh the truth about Muhammad
and uh he's also published the
politically incorrect guide to Islam.
So these gentlemen will will be debating
and hopefully we'll answer some of those
questions that a lot of you here are
wondering as well. At the very end I I
hope to open up the debate to you and
have you ask our panelists some
questions. Okay, without any further
ado, let's bring up Dr. Daniel Peterson
from Brigham Brigham Y Young University.
There's no clear answer to the question
whether Islam is violent or peaceful.
For one thing, there's no single
Platonic archetype somewhere out there
called Islam. There are and always have
been competing Islams, each claiming to
be the authentic one, just as there's no
single monolithic Judaism, but rather as
the great scholar Jacob Neners has
observed, Judaisms. And just as there
are Catholic, Protestant, Orthodox,
Quaker, and many other Christianities,
Sunni Islam differs from Shi Islam. And
Sunni Islam alone recognizes as Orthodox
four distinct schools of legal thought.
This isn't to mention Sufi or mystical
Islam, which transcends the Sunni Shiite
divide, nor such sex as the Wahhabis and
others. Further, the question is too
black and white. Obviously, one cannot
simplistically pronounce Islam a
religion of peace. Muhammad was neither
a proto Gandhi nor some kind of 7th
century Arabian flowerchild.
But it's an equal and opposite arrow to
depict Islam simplistically as an
ideology of hatred, violence, and
oppression. Like every other religious
faith and every other institution
involving humans, Islam's historical
record is mixed. With those cautions
stated, a better way of phrasing the
topic of today's discussion would be,
islam inherently violent in all its
forms or not? To which my answer is no.
Before I set forth some of my reasons
for this answer in the painfully limited
period allotted, so many disagreements,
so little time, permit me to say where
I'm not coming from. I'm neither a
Muslim nor an apologist for Islam. I'm a
believing Christian, nor am I a
leftwinger or a cultural relativist. I
don't believe that the Islamic world is
beyond criticism, and I see much to
criticize. I don't think that the
connection between Islam and terrorist
violence is accidental or coincidence.
Moreover, I'm a movement conservative,
for what it's worth, with libertarian
leanings, a subscriber to National
Review since I was 13, who supports the
surge in Iraq and the war in
Afghanistan. I am, however, a student of
Islam and of Islamic intellectual
history. Muslims currently represent
nearly a quarter of the human race, and
they're not likely to go away anytime
soon, nor are they likely to simply walk
away from their faith. So my fundamental
question to those who claim that Islam
properly understood is inherently
violent, that it's inescapably hostile
to liberty and western civilization is
this. What would you have us do? I don't
suppose though Sam Harris comes close
that anybody seriously proposes a
western war of annihilation against the
world's roughly 1.3 billion Muslims. But
if Islam is inherently violent and
hostile, I see no real alternative to a
permanent state of war between the West
and Islam, I reject the idea.
Unfortunately though, I think that our
harshest western critics make such a
clash of civilizations more likely. How?
Because ironically in privileging those
readings of Islam that demand a
permanent state of war between the darl
Islam, the abode of Islam or submission
and the darl harb the abode of war, a
pair of entirely non-Quranic phrases.
Incidentally, they read it exactly as
our most ardent and implacable enemies
do. And in arguing that this is the only
true and legitimate understanding of
Islam, they agree with seed kot Osama
bin Laden. I'm in a zoahiri and other
extremists in declaring moderate Muslims
to be kufur or infidels. This seems to
me catastrophically wrongheaded. Not
only because it's historically mistaken,
but perhaps even more importantly
because it undercuts members of the
Muslim community whom we ought to be
cheering on. A few weeks ago, I was
driving with a Muslim friend in Jordan.
We're living in a stupid period of
Islamic history, he told me. I hope that
people won't judge all of Islam, Islamic
civilization, and Islamic history by
this stupid period. To that in the
context of this discussion I add my hope
that we in the west won't do anything to
support stupidity or to delegitimize
intelligence among our Muslim neighbors
the old Latin precept first do no harm
can and should apply to intercultural
relations as well as to medicine modern
mujahedin do not believe they are
hijacking Islam Robert Spencer rightly
notes they believe they're restoring its
proper interpretation and they're
successfully convincing peaceful Muslims
around the world that they're correct
and they will continue to do so for as
long as peaceful Muslims failed to
formulate new and nonliteralist ways of
interpreting the Quran and the words and
deeds of Muhammad. In his books,
however, Mr. Spencer effectively argues
that the Wahhabis and al-Qaeda and their
fellow travelers represent true Islam.
Far from being extremists or perverters
of the faith, he writes they interpret
its texts correctly. They are the people
who actually dare to do what Allah says
to do. He argues that non-Muslims who
don't recognize this live in a fantasy
world and most crucially that moderate
Muslims to the extent that they exist
are moderates either because they aren't
serious Muslims or because they're
ignorant of the real teachings of their
faith. This is precisely the position of
Sage Put and the other founders of
today's militant Islamism. If true, it
would be deeply disheartening. It would
suggest that if Muslims learn about
their faith and follow it, they must
logically practice the jihadi extremist
form of Islam. In my judgment, however,
this idea is not true. As outlined in
John Kelsey's important book, Arguing
the Just War and Islam, there's a
serious intra-Islamic conversation going
on, and the moderates have a case. And I
could not possibly disagree more
strongly with Mr. Spencer and the
Wahhabies when they claimed the mystical
or Sufi tradition of Islam, which has
often expressed itself peacefully and
tolerantly is not true Islam. To oppose
aggressive military jihad, Mr. Spencer
says, would be to turn against Islam
itself.
In seeing the war on terror as not just
as a war against Islam but as a war on
behalf of Christianity, Mr. Spencer
writes, "The view of Bin Laden and other
jihad terrorists neatly coaleses with
that of the anti-Christian theocracy
writers like Chris Hedges and Kevin
Phillips." Mr. Spencer's fullthroated
sustained defense of the Crusades as
justified defensive warfare. And his
expressions of gratitude to the
crusaders suggest that he, Hedges,
Phillips, and Osama aren't so very far
apart on this matter. And no Muslim who
opens to the frontest piece of Mr.
Spencer's politically incorrect guide uh
to Islam to see the two words that
appear alone and in all capital letters
on it. Deos vult is likely to be
reassured. Deos vault, Latin for God
wills it was the cry of the people at
the declaration of the first crusade by
Pope Urban II in 1095.
Even many conservatives shy away from
naming the enemy, Mr. Spencer writes,
for fear that it means war against a
billion Muslims. But if Mr. Spencer's
arguments are granted, doesn't it? It's
a PC myth he has written in the context
of a discussion not of fringe terrorists
but of mainstream Islam and Islamic
history that we can negotiate with these
people quote unquote.
Even many conservatives shy away from
naming the enemy, Mr. Spencer writes,
for fear that it means war against a
billion Muslims. But if Mr. Spencer's
arguments are granted, doesn't it? It's
a PC myth he has written in the context
of a discussion not of fringe terrorists
but of mainstream Islam and Islamic
history that we can negotiate with these
people quote unquote. There's scarcely a
single ray of light in Mr. Spencer's
relentlessly negative portrayal of Islam
and Islamic civilization which seem
beyond redemption and which it appears
must be utterly repudiated. Accordingly,
for example, Muslim Spain and the
Ottoman Empire, widely recognized by
mainstream scholars as relatively
tolerant places compared with then
contemporary Europe, weren't tolerant at
all. Islamic law, lie, steal, and kill,
reads one of his chapter headings. He
even denigrates Muslim contributions to
science and philosophy. It is thus
stunningly ironic to read Mr. Spencer's
lament that, quote, "Islamic theology so
devalues non-believers that there's no
room in Islamic culture for any
generosity toward their achievements."
End quote.
There seems no place at all in Mr.
Spencer's world for believing Muslims.
As long as men read and believe the
Quran, Mr. Spencer writes in his
politically incorrect guide, women will
be despised secondass citizens, subject
to the loss of virtually all of the most
basic human freedoms. The war on terror,
he declares in the opening sentence of
his book, Religion of Peace, is an
ideological conflict, one in which
Christians, Jews, Buddhists, Hindus,
atheists, secular Muslims, and others
have a stake. Notice that while secular
Muslims are included as potential
allies, believing Muslims are
conspicuously omitted. And now a few
points of many. The Quran says Mr.
Spencer exhorts believers to fight
unbelievers. The commands taken at face
value are open-ended and universal.
However, it's just as possible to take
them as exhortations to fight specific
hostile unbelievers in Arabia in the
early 7th century. Neither open-ended
nor universal. It's essential to know
the context of Quranic verses. what
Muslims call the asbab and nul the
reasons for sending down or occasions of
revelation. Mr. Spencer puts aggressive
military jihad at the absolute heart of
Islam, suggesting that doing otherwise
is untrue to the classical texts. But
the 8th century jurist Jur regarded
prayer and mosque attendance as more
important and did not consider jihad
obligatory for all. Al Bkari Muslim and
Midi report a saying of Muhammad
indicating helping widows and the poor
is jihad. Another report has Muhammad
telling a man to go home and care for
his parents rather than going out to
fight. The early jurist Sufyana Tawi
believed that jihad was primarily
defensive and that the only and that
only defensive jihad was obligatory upon
individual Muslims. So did the prominent
20th century recctor of Alazar
University in Cairo, Muhammad Shelut.
Mr. Spencer says that the Quranic phrase
jihad for Sabil law striving in the path
of God means armed struggle to establish
the hijgemony of the Islamic social
order. This is to say the least of it
debatable. The Arabic word jihad means
simply striving. The mossaf abdi uh in
the 9th century for instance in addition
to the military defense of Islamic lands
offers striving daily to live
righteously through acts of worship as a
specimen of jihad along with earning a
legal livelihood and serving one's
family. Other early sources mentioned
the pursuit of knowledge, spending money
on a good cause, prayer, giving alms,
and even patience or patient endurance
as examples of non-military jihad.
Curiously, the word harab or war is
never conjoined with the term jihad in
the Quran. Mr. Spencer writes of
Muhammad's alleged ambitions of world
domination. However, modern scholars
like Montgomery Watt and Carl Erns
reject them as later retro retrojections
from the imperial period. Even if the
voices of moderation are rare, muted,
and too often in exile, which I grant,
there's a genuine discussion going on
within Islam. John Kelsey's arguing the
just war in Islam, Carl Ernst's
Following Muhammad, rethinking Islam in
a contemporary world are two recent
books that chronicle portions of that
discussion. The essays gathered in
Charles Curtsman's source book entitled
Liberal Islam and Asmas Faradin's
Admiral Mulun book, The First Muslims
History and Memory, are illustrations of
it. Scholars like Ruama Ahmed, Abdul
Aziz Sachadina, the late Fazul Rahman,
UCLA's Khaled Abul Figure in it. Ali
Abdul Razi argued that no particular
form of government is required by Islam,
that a social order compatible with
Islam simply requires justice and
equity. There's considerable debate
about the reliability of the Hadith,
which have been used to justify jihadi
violence. The contemporary Iranian
philosopher Abdul Kharim Souch argues
for the legitimacy of religious
pluralism. And in North Africa, Muhammad
Talby contends Islamically for religious
liberty. We should be careful not to
undercut such people, nor to award the
victor's crown to their opponents. They
have a difficult enough challenge as it
is.
Thank you.
Ladies and gentlemen, we're fortunate
enough to have Robert Spencer himself to
respond to some of the accusations and
some of the statements uh Dr. Peterson
made. I also want to point out that
Robert Spencer will be available to the
public at a book signing after this uh
4:15, booth 4:15. And without further
ado, the director of the Jihad Watch,
which is a news and commentary site
that's updated daily, Robert Spencer.
Thank you.
So many things to say and so little
time. The question is uh uh whether to
speak about the elements of Islam that
are used by jihadists to justify
violence and supremacism and oppression
in various ways is to validate those
interpretations of Islam and to undercut
those Muslims who are trying to reform
those things. This is a very important
question and I don't think that it can
be approached unless we have an accurate
understanding of the facts on the
ground. Dr. Peterson quite correctly
stated at the beginning of his talk that
there is no single Islam that there is
in the first place the Sunni and Shiite
divide and in the second place four
schools of Sunni juristprudence
as well as other schools of
juristprudence.
uh he did not mention however that there
is a broad consensus and consensus is a
very important is a very important uh
concept in Islamic theology. I Muhammad
prophesied that his community would not
agree on an error and so what is reached
as a point of consensus by the various
schools of Islamic law is considered to
be a question that is settled and sure.
Now this is Islamic theology. This is
not my opinion. And these are matters of
record that the schools of Islamic
juristprudence do agree and have a
consensus on the necessity to wage war
against unbelievers. Dr. Peterson
mentioned the four schools of Sunni
juristprudence, the Shafi, Maliki,
Hanafi and Hanbali. All of them agree
that jihad is a precept of divine
institution that it is uh preferable to
first invite the non-Muslims to accept
Islam and if they refuse to fight them.
I am uh quoting in part the words of Ibn
Abi Za Kaiani who was a Maliki jurist,
the jurist from one of these schools of
juristprudence and Kaiwani was actually
working from the words of Muhammad
himself as recorded in the hadith
collection sakim Muslim when he said to
meet the unbelievers invite them to
accept Islam if they refuse invite them
to enter the Islamic social order as as
the demise the secondass citizens as
mandated by Islamic law and an
institutionalized
uh status of discrimination. The they
would not enjoy equality of rights under
the law with the Muslims. And if they
refuse both to go to war with them,
conversion, subjugation or war being set
out by Muhammad in what are considered
to be canonical hadith, hadith that are
authentic by all the schools of Islamic
law and all the orthodox sects of Islam.
Now the a lot of the confusion comes
from the difficulty of dealing with
these facts. This is not to say that
there that no modern reformers exist. It
is to say that it is an element of
traditional and mainstream Islam and a
point of agreement among the various
differing sects of Islam that warfare
against unbelievers and their
subjugation under the rule of Islamic
law is part of the responsibility of the
Muslim community. Now he says that if
this is true, Dr. Peterson says that
this would be very disheartening.
Unfortunately, there are some truths
that are disheartening. And what we have
to do is realistically work from that
point to try to come up with some kind
of a solution that is actually workable
rather than retreat into fantasies,
halftruths, and deceptions that are much
more comforting, much more heartening,
but unfortunately false.
Unfortunately, there are some truths
that are disheartening. And what we have
to do is realistically work from that
point to try to come up with some kind
of a solution that is actually workable
rather than retreat into fantasies,
halftruths, and deceptions that are much
more comforting, much more heartening,
but unfortunately false.
Now in this case if there is a permanent
state of war existing between the uh
house of Islam the dal Islam and the
house of war the dalar which is us then
it is because Muslims who believe these
teachings are waging it and always have
been waging it. And the only times in
history when there has not been
widespread jihad violence in the world
is at times when the Islamic community
was too weak to put it forward. But not
because there was any large-scale reform
of these teachings, rejection of these
teachings, even reconsideration of these
teachings. This is not to say that every
Muslim in the world is our enemy, should
be our enemy, or ever will be fighting
against us. Because as in in Islam, as
in every other religious tradition,
there is a spectrum of belief, of
knowledge, and of fervor. There are many
millions of people around the world,
billions in fact, who call themselves
Christians. And yet to con assume that
they all agree on Christian doctrine or
that they all will act upon Christian
doctrines that they agree on would be
absurd. There is a huge variation in how
those people who call themselves
Christians live out their Christianity
or are Christians essentially in name
only and ignore part or all of it. It's
the same way in Islam. These things are
teachings of all the schools of Islamic
law. These things are manifestly taught
in the Quran. They are taught in the
example of Muhammad who aswah Hassana
the perfect example the supreme
excellent example of conduct as
specified in the Quran is to be imitated
held up as a model for emulation in
Islamic theology. And as these things
are taught then there are people who
will take them seriously. There are
people who will not take them seriously.
There are people who will hear them and
believe them but not be willing to give
up their comfortable lives. They just
want to have a job and a family. They
just want to be left alone. They don't
really can't really be bothered with all
these theological issues.
There is also because of the great
western influence including the
influence of western pop culture which
has been so derided in the Islamic
world. There is also a widespread
acceptance of western sentiments of
western notions of human rights that are
at variance with classical notions of
Islamic law. The Quran, not Spencer, not
uh some extremists, mandates amputation
of the hand for theft. That's chapter
5:38. Uh the hadith, the Islamic
traditions and Islamic law are unanimous
on that. They are unanimous on the
stoning of adulterers. They are
unanimous on the institutionalized
subjugation of women in many ways. But
the world is not, the Islamic world is
not hermetically sealed. Western ideas
have come in. And there are millions,
hundreds of millions of Muslims who do
subscribe to Western notions of human
rights, western notions of the dignity
of all people and the equality of rights
of all people before the law. These
people can be our allies. But both
within the Islamic world and in terms of
the Islamic world's relations to the
West, these things cannot come about if
we don't acknowledge the situation
first. You can't reform what you won't
admit needs reforming. You can't fix
what you won't admit is broken. The
reformers such as Khaled Abu Al whom Dr.
Peterson mentioned are actually uh
people who are not the kind of reformer
you would expect. If you're familiar
with European history, you're familiar
with the Protestant Reformation, whether
you were a Catholic or a Protestant or
whether you were neither, then you may
know that the Protestant reformers
pointed out elements of Catholic
theology that they rejected and they
taught against them. They fought against
them. They said, "We do not believe and
we do not think that the church ought to
teach transubstantiation, papal
authority, veneration of Mary and so
on." They did not say
these elements of Christianity do not
exist and have never existed and anybody
who thinks so is just helping the
extremists.
And it's the same way today. If we're
going to really help genuine Islamic
reformers, we shouldn't prot then we
cannot take those people and there are
many including some that uh Dr. Peterson
mentioned who are saying that these
elements of Islam do not exist and have
never existed.
That's not reform. That's deception. We
can take as allies those who say there
are these elements of Islam and they
need to be rethought. There needs to be
a fundamental reassessment of how we
take even the literal words of the
Quran. And there may need to be a
retreat from an explicit retreat from
literalism in several particulars.
But this problem will never go away.
This problem will not be solved. This
problem will continue to recur if we in
the first place forbid ourselves from
speaking about it. and we are end up
pretending that it doesn't exist and
accepting the comforting half-truths and
inaccurate formulations of people who
have not actually confronted the reality
of these things. Just for example, Dr.
Peterson mentioned that uh there are
interpretations of the Quran that are
put forward by the jihadists today and
that I am endorsing them and validating
them supposedly by writing about them
and reporting on them. and that he
reminds me that we have to take into
account the azbaban nazul which is the
context of the various verses of the
Quran. Well, let me give you a little
lesson inbabul right here just very
briefly.
Ibanis hak the first biographer of
Muhammad in the 8th century a pious
Muslim explains the contexts of various
Quranic verses about warfare not
necessarily about jihad as Dr. Peterson
points out quite rightly, jihad means
struggle. There are many struggles in
Arabic, just as there are many struggles
in English. You can struggle to quit
smoking and you can have a great
struggle against the communist world.
It's the same word. But there's no doubt
that jihad warfare is an element of
this. And there's more. Ibanis Hak says
there are there are places in the Quran
where Muhammad the Quran teaches peace.
Surah 109 of the Quran says you have say
to the unbelievers you have your
religion and I have mine. essentially
let's leave each other alone. That's
great. I would I I can go for that. But
Ibn is Hak says there are also portions
of the Quran which teach warfare which
say fight against those who have fought
against you but do not begin
hostilities. And then there's that's
chapter 2 vers 190. And then there are
further passages such as chapter 9 29
which says fight against the people of
the book that's Jews and Christians
primarily
until they pay the Jiza which is the tax
the religion-based tax specified in
Islamic law with willing submission and
feel themselves subdued in other words
fight against the Jews and Christians
until they submit to the rule of the
Muslims. Now Ibnban is hak says in
context the first set of verses verse uh
the ones that are broadly tolerant came
from the early part of Muhammad's career
when he was a preacher he was not a
military leader and he was essentially
powerless then when he moved to Medina
and he became for the first time a
political and military leader he began
to tell the Muslims to defend themselves
and that's the second stage of Quranic
revelation according to Iban is hak not
to Spencer of the teachings on jihad and
finally he says that the Quran because
the Muslims are the best of people
that's chapter 3 110 and the unbelievers
are the most vile of created beings
that's chapter 98:6
therefore the Muslims must fight in
order to extend their hegemony over the
rule the world because this is the law
of God and they have the responsibility
to spread the law of God everywhere now
in other words what he's saying is there
are three stages of Quranic development
on warfare and the third and final stage
that is applicable for all time is
warfare against unbelievers. I didn't
make that up. That is the earliest
biographer of Muhammad. Every biographer
of Muhammad since then, including Dr.
Peterson, has to rely at least in part
on his writings. And that theological
point that he makes about the context of
the Quranic verses is mainstream Islam
taught by all the schools of Islamic
law. I am all for Muslims who reject
that. I am all for Muslims who say we
have to move beyond that. But I do not
trust Muslims who say that does not
exist and that is not so.
That is not reform again. That is
deception. We need not to be deceived
here. We cannot afford to allow
ourselves to be deceived. And as
Muhammad said, war is deceit. And that
war, deception, deliberate lying is
allowed in times of warfare in which we
are manifestly in one today or many
Muslims believe we are. And when Muslims
are under pressure from unbelievers, as
specified by Quran 3:28, they may
pretend to be their friends while
actually working against them. These
things have to be recognized as being
elements of Quranic teaching, the
teachings of Muhammad, the teachings of
Islamic law. Without that first
recognition, there can be no genuine
reform and no genuine movement toward
any kind of resolution of this conflict.
And one thing we can be certain of in
that event is that if voices like Dr.
Peterson's prevail, the war will
continue and intensify for the
foreseeable future. Thank you.
All right. The last time these two
gentlemen met up, uh Dr. Peterson and uh
Mr. Spencer for the most part agreed.
They had a debate on a radio station.
Today, Dr. Peterson would like to ask uh
Mr. Spencer a couple of questions. We'll
take it from there. Also, afterwards, I
want to open up the questions to the
audience. There are two microphones in
the middle aisle and um we'll have a Q&A
session with uh with the audience
afterwards. So you can ask both our
panelists your questions. Dr. Peterson,
you can you can
>> Okay,
I assume this is on. Yeah. Um I wonder
if I could just respond to some [music]
things we were said. First of all, I I
want to stress um I am not one of those
living in a fantasy world who who thinks
that Islam is peaceful right now. Um I
think the Islamic world is dysfunctional
[music] right now and clearly that the
militant voices have the upper hand.
they're winning and uh and the
moderates, the people that I would like
to see win are on the defensive uh if
they're even doing that well. Uh in many
places, they're simply silent uh for
various reasons, some of which are
understandable, some of which bother me
exceedingly much. Um
I I'm not opposed to uh to Mr. Spencer's
critique of Islam on many levels. I
think it's sort of a bracing tonic, and
I think there's much that the Islamic
world needs to do to respond to the sort
of critique that comes from Mr. Spencer.
Um, what my problem with with a lot of
what he's done, I think, is not so much
that it's wrong as that it's selective,
that it's a prosecutor's brief, which
has a legitimate function. Um, but but
there's some things I'd like to say. I I
see my position. We're not really so
much opposed uh here. You know, if this
debate were a debate between polar
opposites, you'd have someone arguing
that Islam was intrinsically violent,
someone arguing it's intrinsically
peaceful. I'm not going to argue that. I
think that the elements of justifying
warfare are definitely there. This is
certainly a very important part of the
[music] Islamic tradition and it's
something that Muslims need to deal
with. My simple argument is that that
there's a lot of material there and it's
legitimates in the tradition that can be
used by moderates. Um and uh yes, there
is a broad consensus and has been for a
long time about certain elements of
jihadi teaching. I'd like to point out
though that formulations like the
opposition between the binary opposition
between the darlhad and the darl of
Islam the abotive war and the abode of
submission um that opposition is
something that dates really to about two
centuries after the prophet Muhammad u
much of Islamic law relative to jihad
and almost everything else was
formulated during the imperial period
and expansionist period you can see the
the jurists who are doing this as as the
kind of hawkish pro pro-establishment
party um
giving comfort to the enemy here.
[laughter]
Um but this is the war party and they're
curing favor in some senses I think with
the uh with the establishment with the
regime [music] by justifying what the
regime is doing. But all I really need
to do to demonstrate there are peaceful
elements within Islam is is to show that
there are some out there. It's like uh
tried to disprove the proposition that
all crows are black. All I have to do is
show one white crow and I've succeeded.
So in that sense, I've got a modest task
here. Um let me just let me just go over
a couple of the verses that that are
mentioned. Um for example, it said that
that the Quran explicitly teaches never
ending warfare against unbelievers. Uh
that is one of the things I expressly
denied in my opening statement. The
Quran, you could read it as simply
referring to the specific wars that
Muhammad was involved in 7th century
Arabia. to generalize from that to a
state of never-ending war against all
the rest of the non-Muslim world is not
a necessary entailment of those
passages. Now that it has been the
entailment for a lot of Muslims, maybe
the dominant tradition is no doubt true.
Uh but I think there are other ways of
reading it. For example, um the
so-called sword verse Quran 95 reads,
"And when the sacred months are over,
slay the polytheists wherever you find
them. Take them captive, besiege them,
and lie and wait for them at every
conceivable place." But the references
in that verse to polytheists, not just
non-believers, it's polytheists. And the
reference to the sacred monks make clear
this verse refers specifically to the
pagan Arabs of Muhammad's time. In fact,
that's how many early scholars such as
in the 8th century, the great the
greatest of the Quran commentators got
in the early 10th century. That's how
they understood it. The verse that he
that Mr. Spencer expressly quoted um
conjoined with the sword verse is Quran
9:29 which reads fight against those who
despite having been given revelation
before do not believe in God nor in the
last day and do not consider forbidden
that which God his messenger have
forbidden and do not follow the religion
of the truth until they pay the Jizu
with willing hand having been subdued.
Now this verse obviously doesn't refer
to all Christians and Jews but only to
those who disbelieve in God and fail to
forbid evil. Contrast what Quran 3:es
113-15 says about devoted Christians and
Jews. They are not all the same. Among
the people of the book are a contingent
who stand in prayer reciting the verses
of God at all times of the night while
they prostrate themselves. These are
they who believe in God in the last day
and enjoy what is right and forbid what
is wrong. They hasten to perform good
deeds. They are among the righteous and
whatever they do of good will not be
rejected by God. And God knows best. Who
are the god-fearing? So this idea that
it's a blanket invitation war against
all Christians and Jews seems to me even
if many Muslims have taken that way
taken it that way seems to me one that
you can you can construct a legitimate
argument against and I'm just hoping for
the success of people who will make that
argument. Sorry.
Thanks for the pen. Yeah. Uh so am I
hoping for the success of people who
make that argument. But once again, my
constant refrain is in this. Let's not
kid ourselves. Uh there are other ways
of reading the Quran. Sure, I am all for
somebody coming in tomorrow and making
up a whole new way to read the Quran to
eliminate the uh power of any of these
verses and many others that we can quote
to incite people to violence and to make
them pursue a supremacist agenda against
the West. But the fact is that the
mainstream understandings as Dr. appears
and is conceited of these verses is not
that way. We can make up pretty things
out of the Quran all that we want. But
the point the only reason to even
perform the exercise would be to help
Muslims to actually understand the Quran
this way. Uh and for example, you take
take some of the things that uh Dr.
Peterson has pointed out that chapter
9:29 refers only as he says to uh
fighting against those Jews and
Christians who disbelieve in Allah.
Well, since Allah is just the word for
God, it might seem nice if you stop
there because you think, well, Jews and
Christians by definition believe in God.
And so that means they're only fighting
against Jews and Christians who perhaps
aren't very religious. But the reality
of the situation is it says fight
against the people of the book that is
Jews and Christians who disbelieve in
Allah and his messenger. That is the
Allah and Muhammad. The Jews and
Christians in other words who who have
tarity not to convert to Islam. They are
the ones who have to be fought and that
would be all those who remain Jews and
Christians and don't become Muslims.
This is validated by many many hadith
and many many statements of the taps the
commentaries on the Quran and Islamic
law and history. Uh for it's very
comforting perhaps to read. I can give
you a verse you could use says chapter 2
62 which says that the believers Jews
and Christians and nobody knows exactly
word but Jews and Christians we know
will go to paradise. And that sounds
great. How how wonderful and ecumenical
until you read the commentary such as
that by Iban Kadir who is mainstream
accepted commentator on the Quran and uh
the tseline which is another one another
commentary that is very widely accepted
and respected by Muslims. And they both
say the Jews and Christians who go to
heaven are the ones who convert to
Islam.
The bad ones state Jews and Christians.
The uh I didn't ever say that. I never
say a lot of things that have been
attributed to me today, but I didn't say
that there were no peaceful elements of
Islam. There are many peaceful elements
of Islam, but the fact that the Nazis
did social services doesn't mean they
didn't incinerate Jews. Uh the the there
are peaceful elements of Islam,
wonderful elements of Islam. Beautiful.
I wouldn't have studied Islam all these
years if there weren't so many beautiful
and compelling elements within it. But
here again, we can't kid ourselves.
There are also violent supremacist
elements of it that do exist and that
Muslims believe. And no matter how we
may make up some nice ways to get around
them, until Muslims worldwide on a
widespread basis start formulating those
same kinds of ways to get around them,
then we're just playing games and making
ourselves feel better. And uh what is
it? What's the expression? Playing
shuffle board on the bridge of the
Titanic.
Uh there's no doubt that the doctrines
of warfare were indeed, as Dr. Peterson
points out, formulated several centuries
after Muhammad's death and that uh they
were formulated during an imperial
period. There's also no doubt that
they've never been reformed or rejected
and that the apparatus to do so does
exist. There are still these schools of
juristprudence operating and not one of
them has ever said, "Wait a minute, we
we shouldn't wage war against
unbelievers in order to establish the
age of Islamic law against them." They
had a golden opportunity to do this. As
a matter of fact, after 9/11 when there
were people who were pointing out that
these doctrines existed. Then was the
time when the New York Times went to
Alasar University in Cairo and said it
was a beacon of moderation trying to
teach Muslims that warfare was not the
way to go. and Alasar University in
Cairo has given its endorsement to a
manual of Islamic law that says very
clearly that the Muslim community must
wage war against Jews, Christians and
Zoroastrians until they either become
Muslim or pay the non-Muslim pole tax
the Jizia that we both mentioned. Now
they could have rescended their
endorsement of such ideas at that time.
They could have backed up the New York
Times wishful thinking and shown
themselves in some way to be moderate.
They did not do so and there still
continues to be no major Islamic
authority that has done so. And and so
what I am doing in my work is not trying
to make the case any better or worse
than it is. And I invite any fair-minded
person to look at the books that I've
written. I never actually say contrary
to Dr. Peterson's claim that the
jihadist version of Islam is the true
Islam. There is no central authority in
Islam. There's no Islamic quote and
there is no person who can pronounce and
say this is real Islam and this isn't.
But there's no doubt that the jihadists
are using the the claim that they
represent the true Islam and are
butressing that claim by reference to
these traditional elements of Islam to
gain recruits around the Islamic world.
Until we recognize that and challenge it
rather than try to wish it away, it will
continue.
Doc, Dr. Peterson, um, you've mentioned
on several occasions that this may just
be a misunderstanding between the
Western world and non-Muslims and
Muslims. How do you contend that we
should deal with the threat of terrorism
in places, not just inside countries
like Iraq and Afghanistan, but where
it's been exported abroad. We've seen it
in England, uh, France, u, of course the
United States. How do you explain the
phenomenon of of terrorism? How should
the United States or even Western
nations respond to that threat?
>> Well, I don't see it as a
misunderstanding between Muslims and
non-Muslims. I I see it as uh, you know,
there really is, in a sense, we are
really not disagreeing that much, except
I do object to the idea that I'm making
up pretty things in the Quran, playing
games, wishing it away. I'm not. I have
a pretty cold re realistic view of the
Islamic world. Terrorism, Islamic
terrorism really does have roots in in
actual parts of the tradition of Islam.
I'm simply arguing there are people out
there, no major schools yet and no
authorities. There is no Islamic pope to
uh for example to issue some sort of
encyclical denouncing terrorism. Nobody
has that kind of authority. Um but there
are voices out there and some pretty
prominent ones who have who have come
out even even some pretty anti-American
shakes in Saudi Arabia that were
critical of of um of the 9/11 attacks
for example. Uh not as critical as I
would like them to be but they were
critical of those attacks because of
their because of their assault on
[laughter] because of their assault on
civilians and so on and so forth. um and
their in their failure to discriminate
between uh between uh military
combatants and others. Um how would I
like to see us respond? I think that
there's uh you know I've said already
that I'm a supporter of the surge and
I'm a supporter of the war in
Afghanistan. I think a a major military
response is necessary in some areas. I
think we ought to be fighting the war of
ideas in various ways which we're not
doing. At one point, um, I was told that
the US was actually cutting back on
broadcasting of IDEA programs into the
Middle East and was broadcasting
American popular culture, for example,
and I'm not making this up, Britney
Spears. Um, now I can't imagine a
stupider policy than that to reinforce
all the the Islamist stereotypes about
the West. That's the kind of thing we've
we've been doing. Um but uh but there
are elements there are little tiny
elements out there in this very
dysfunctional period of Islamic history
little embryos out there that I'd like
to see us blow upon if we can to fan
them into life. I don't know how we can
do that. This is a very difficult
question. Uh because if you you know if
these people are seen as somehow CIA
supported or something like that that's
death to them. Um but but we ought to be
encouraging, hoping for doing everything
we can to to sort of support the
mainstream support, excuse me, the
moderate reinterpretation of these
elements in front or and in the Islamic
tradition and to to reinforce those
peaceful elements which I insist I'm not
making up. They are there. They're
legitimate interpretations.
Thank you very much. Um they're they're
legitimate interpret I know I'm going to
lose this today. Think think of me as a
martyr. Um, thanks.
>> Don't do that.
>> Hold on.
Gentlemen, afterwards we will you will
have time. You can go up to the
microphone. We have about 10 minutes
left. So, if you do have questions, go
ahead and line up behind the microphone.
I promise I'll get to you.
>> Just enhancing my market complex. Okay.
at
least not a jihadist murder with bomb.
[laughter]
>> I I do want to ask question marks,
Robert Spencer, because this is
important. He probably gets this
criticism all the time. Um, your books
are seen as provocative by a lot of
people and the doctor's making the point
that there are moderate segments of of
uh Muslims and that what you do in fact
is that you you polarize them that that
books like the politically incorrect
guide to Islam and the crusades actually
takes those moderates and polarizes them
and makes them even more uh pro-Islamic
or even pro-terrorists or if if
anything, they just drop out of the
debate, which could be even worse. How
do you respond to that, Robert?
>> Well, actually, I already have uh I uh
mentioned before, you can't fix what you
would admit is broken. You can't reform
what you would admit needs reforming.
Any Muslim who genuinely rejects the
elements of Islam that I'm speaking
about shouldn't have any problem with my
speaking about them. Uh, as a matter of
fact, I take it as a as a kind of an
index as to whether a reformer is
sincere or is a deceiver if he professes
offense at these things because the uh
the the situation is that you have
people who are claiming [music] that
these elements of Islam do not exist.
And as I explained before, I I don't
think that that's reform at all. Uh just
to pretend that they don't exist might
be very comforting to Westerners who
don't know whether they exist or not.
but they will not keep the jihadists who
know very well that these elements of
Islam exist from continuing to exploit
them. And so they have to speak about
these things forthrightly. I also think
it's beyond absurd to think that if you
have a Muslim who abhors jihad violence
and Islamic supremacism that if I speak
about these things, he will suddenly
embrace jihad violence and Islamic
supremacism. Uh also I want to point out
that Dr. Peterson and I both wish to
blow on the embers of the reform. the
very small groups and individuals as he
points out or as he acknowledges that
are working to change what is in Islam
and to mitigate these violent elements.
But here again I do not believe that can
be done simply by uh sugarcoating the
harsh realities of the situation but by
confronting them. And I appeal again to
the uh historical analogy of the
Protestant Reformation. Protestant
reformers did not say the church doesn't
teach transubstantiation and papal
authority and anybody who says so is a
hatemonger and it's going to make me
become a Catholic.
That's the absurd situation we're in.
Now let me just say that that by
portraying this as some people do
presentation I heard yesterday I think
essentially hinted at this uh presenting
this as some sort of war between
Christianity and Islam between the west
and Islam. we do sort of force some
people who who are Muslims believing
Muslims if they if they believe the war
is against Islam and remember a lot of
people over there it's it's not so much
what they it's not so much what the
facts of the of the case really are it's
what they believe that may or may not be
so that can affect their their attitude
toward things if they see the West as
engaged in a war against Islam they will
line up with Islam the enemy of my enemy
>> so on so forth
>> that's an excellent point doctor we have
several guests who want to ask a
question. So, go ahead and step up and
ask your question.
>> Both of the speakers have stated that
there are small minorities within the
>> I'm sorry, sir. Speak up just a little
bit.
>> Both of the speakers have stated that
there are small minorities within Islam
who are moderate. It seems to me that
the extremists have terrorized the
moderates to the point where they are
totally powerless and have are unwilling
to to speak up. Could you comment
please?
>> Yeah, that's quite so. Not only do they
appeal to they make their appeal within
the Islamic communities that is the
jihadists make their appeal within
Islamic communities on the basis of
their Islamic authenticity on the basis
of making saying that they represent
true Islam real Islam and anybody who
does not wage jihad against the west in
some form not necessarily violent form
but in some way trying to help the
effort is not authentic Muslim. Not only
do they do that but they also uh
pronounce the people who reject that the
Muslims who reject these ideas to be
apostate and apostates of course
according to Muhammad's own command if
anybody changes his religion kill him
and according to all the schools of
Islamic law here again in all the
orthodox sects of Islam apostates must
be executed now this doesn't mean that
every apostate will be executed somebody
has to care enough to carry out the
sentence but the sentence is there and
it does intimidate modern Muslim Muslim
that is used to intimidate moderate
Muslims. I'd like to point out also this
is happening right here in the United
States. In Tulsa, Oklahoma, there was a
Muslim, a very courageous man who wrote
a an op-ed in the local paper denouncing
Osama bin Laden whereupon he was
expelled from his mosque in Tulsa,
Oklahoma.
And so if you think that the Muslims in
the United States are free entirely from
these ideas, remember that Shik Muhammad
Hisham Kabani himself a Muslim Sufi
which is as Dr. Peterson said and
accused me of not believing a relatively
peaceful sect. Uh he testified before
State Department open forum as long ago
as 1999
that 80% of the mosques in the United
States are under the control of
extremists. This makes it very difficult
for uh peaceful Muslims and genuine
reformers to make any headway.
>> Dr. Peterson, same question. How do you
marginalize the extremist and uh and
encourage the moderates? I think it's
very difficult and I'm not sure how much
we can really do because once people are
branded western agents their
effectiveness within the Muslim
community is doomed. I might say by the
way there is another way of reading the
uh uh though I agree that that uh the
standard reading within the Islamic
community of the prohibition against
apostasy is there that that it's
deserves the death penalty there's
another way of reading that the word
that's used for apostasy is also related
to the word for rebellion in the early
days of Islam uh uh uhad was was not
only apostasy it was actually sedition
rebellion against legitimate legal
authority which was punishable by death
I think that this now rests on
misreading but unfortunately it's a
widespread misread that we we have time
for one last question. Sorry ladies and
gentlemen it's a quick debate. Thank you
very much for your question sir. Sir
>> quick question for the panel. [music]
>> Isn't this really about the search for
power and and whether it's dressed up as
religion or whether it's dressed up as
nationalism. Looking at your example.
>> Excellent question. We have one minute
left. panelist we have
>> non-Muslims have absolutely no right to
wield the reigns of power in any part of
God's earth and if they do the believers
are under the obligation to dislodge
them from that power by any means
possible that is a quotation from Malana
Maldudi who was who died in 1979 he was
the founder of Jamaati Islami which is
still the largest Islamist political
party in Pakistan and that is the basis
on the basis of the Quran and so on that
there's no right to for non-Muslims to
have political power and it is on that
basis that they're fighting today.
>> Dr. Peterson, is this a power grab?
>> Uh, I'm I'm sure it is. And I think
religion is an incredibly powerful
symbol system and it's obviously
something that resonates in the Middle
East. I might note, by the way, that
despite the fact that in theory,
supposedly according, it's illegal for a
non-Muslim to exercise power. Uh, the
prime minister of Egypt or medieval
Islamic period was often Christian, many
of the wazers in medieval Islamic Spain
were Jewish. Ladies and gentlemen,
>> because they were Jewish.
Nevertheless,000 killed in Granada in
1066.
>> We're going to have to cut it there.
It's a long debate.